how are you feeling i literally played
that song
uh you had a bad day i wrote down some
points because my brain is like
mush lately sad worried
stressed basically like all of the
negative emotions
this probably sounds super familiar and
that's because a lot of us
are feeling stressed right now but this
isn't normal stress
this is pandemic stress and it is
messing with our brains in a very
specific way when you get stressed it
triggers a chain reaction that starts in
the amygdala
your emotional processing headquarters
your eyes and ears send info to the
amygdala
and it determines if what you're seeing
and hearing is stressful
if it is it sends a signal to your
command center the hypothalamus
it's in charge of getting the word out
to the rest of your body by way of the
autonomic nervous system
the adrenal glands get the message first
and pump adrenaline into your
bloodstream
your heart beats faster you breathe more
rapidly
because your muscles need extra blood
and your brain needs extra oxygen
they're preparing to react to whatever
threat is causing your stress response
all this happens in the blink of an eye
it's like how people can jump out of the
way of a car
without really thinking about it the
emotional amygdala basically overrides
your prefrontal cortex
the part of your brain where all the
logic happens so you don't get a chance
to think things through
you just react once the threat dies down
though
the parasympathetic nervous system takes
over and returns all those heightened
reactions to normal
but if the brain still detects danger
after the initial adrenaline rush the
hypothalamus sends out another message
to the rest of the hpa axis
this triggers another series of hormones
that lead to the release of cortisol
which signals to the body that it needs
to stay on high alert and keep pumping
out stress hormones
right now for a lot of us that threat is
still very much alive
the amygdala is still overriding the
prefrontal cortex
which is in charge of decision making
and planning so those feelings of
forgetfulness and tiredness they're
likely a product of this stress response
that won't turn off
stress hormones and the accompanying
bodily responses
are super helpful in the short term but
our bodies aren't
meant to function in this heightened
state for weeks or months at a time
and over time the brain will burn out
when it does it can lead to something
called allostatic load
the cumulative wear and tear that
happens to your body when you're dealing
with chronic stress
a high prolonged level of cortisol can
mess with a lot of stuff
it's even been seen to decrease the
volume of your hippocampus
the area responsible for learning and
memory and a reduced hippocampus is more
often seen in people with
depression than those without so all
this is to say
that the extra stress is probably not
doing your brain or your body any favors
and humans are historically really bad
at making decisions
when they don't know what's going to
happen so what can you do to reduce
allostatic load
reduce stress eating well exercising and
maintaining a regular sleep schedule
cannot be overlooked
exercising alone can reduce stress
hormones even with just a 20-minute walk
and a different way of thinking could
also help us an idea called
model-free learning it's basically trial
and error
instead of basing your risk assessment
on similar examples from the past or
envisioning future scenarios
you just take it one step at a time this
way you reassess and
update your own estimate of what's
happening and how to prepare
we're dealing with a new virus
constantly changing policies
and likely a completely different
schedule and maybe even environment
our brain is on high alert at all times
to identify potential threats
which means that even if you're spending
most of your time laying around
your brain isn't so try not to beat
yourself up for feeling
tired or fuzzy or unmotivated you just
don't need anything else to stress about
now that you know all this how are you
feeling to be honest i do still feel the
same
i think i'm feeling a bit better after
watching it it's actually my body is
exhausted from
feeling things and being under stress
all day all the time whenever i feel
that allostatic load
starting to weigh down on me you know i
can put a name on it a face on it
and it makes it a lot easier to deal
with it